hey man uh yeah I've been thinking about
it if you I can't do it aw come on night
it's been three months it's trying to
get back out there just a date so are
you going into the Hunger Games all
right I'm just gonna say it
it's weird that you're always
referencing your own movies ooh sassy
Josh you are catching your fire buddy
yes he like like that doesn't make any
sense
let's just remember two things be sure
and always complement on us it's a
classic Hemsworth one-two punch that
worked with Miley we said I'll be right
there with you fly Mel King Joe
[Music]
hey sir that's me Josh I like your
sweater thank you I love your nose did
you just say you liked my nose no excuse
me though I'm sorry hey how's it going
you did a nice thing yet she loved it
what are you talking about we just
talked five seconds ago yeah I'm just so
excited okay I'm gonna go now wait a
second how did you I'm sorry
I feel like we got off on the wrong foot
what I meant to say of course is I love
your scarf thank you I like your taste
good this is good okay Josh what the
are you doing down there did you
mention this goth yet I described she's
saved a loss so please stay out of this
I know you earned that you're owning
this for me yeah he's talking to his
penis why do I always get the
Psychopaths I need you I need you later
I will call you okay
[Music]
that's a winner we should order our
waiter ah see you ready to order Josh I
mean complete stranger guy isn't it
romantic you two must be on a date isn't
it romantic is actually a new film by
the way yeah we know that I didn't know
that and I don't care
that's Josh doing it's such a
good guy isn't he just meet my friend
William this is just a costume not
really a waiter it's like in the movies
just giving my uh my friend Josh a
little dating help here you were Cyrano
de Bergerac
Aladdin she's a smart one I did Josh
complement you knows yet
excuse me Liam I'm just gonna go to the
restroom okay she's going the wrong way
he's actually using the exit yep there
she goes why she can't pee in the street
it's a bit weird isn't it you don't
wanna do something like that anyway come
on let's get some beers on you I am me
white uh real waiter
[Music]
hey who's your favorite Hemsworth you're
in the top three that's
[Music]
you